okay well we're seeing what's up with
people on the phone line six one seven
eight three zero
4750 is the number let's go to our next
caller from the 303 area code caller
from 303 tell us who you are and what's
on your mind today I am Joel all right
speak up for us Joel as much as you can
I'm sorry ah yeah I think maybe what's
your question alright so I keep having
arguments about what you with basically
a state tax how you know the wealth
distribution the usual conservative
answer I get it
shouldn't we be entitled to give what
we've earned to our children and and so
on and so forth that troubles with that
rebuttal to this could you help out okay
yeah and I think I think you might be
having some kind of cellphone connection
issue so there's a couple different
things to talk about here the arguments
are numerous numerous different ones one
is it has to do with the fact that
there's this double taxation argument
often made with the state tax that
you're taxing money twice but the truth
is that if someone invests money in
stocks and then they pass those stocks
on to an heir and those stocks are worth
way more unless they've sold those
stocks they've never actually paid taxes
on the capital gains so a lot of the
money that is in estates is not actually
money that through the estate tax is
being taxed a second time that's number
one number two is the fact that there is
absolutely no economic benefit
whatsoever when you go beyond the five
and a half million dollar per person
exemption in the estate tax which for a
couple is 11 million dollars I mean that
would be removed by the Trump tax plan
but that's what it is right now there's
no economic benefit you you get the
first 11 million from your parents
without it being subject to the estate
tax right so the idea right that you're
being unduly burdened by having an
estate tax on everything above and
beyond those 11 million
dollars that's impacting 0.2% of the
population so this unfair burden thing
is is ridiculous and at the bottom line
philosophically what what really impacts
your question is that that money was
generated by the Commons and buy
everything from depending on exactly how
the money was generated our public
education system roads bridges
infrastructure etc etc etc so the idea
that you were solely entitled to 100
percent of those dollars without ever
paying a tax on it you need to suspend
belief in some pretty basic realities of
our world in order to come up with that
argument yeah I agree
it's very it's very hard to get people
to understand just how much wealth yeah
a billion dollars is young and I do
appreciate your answer and these people
you're arguing with along do they have a
state of eleven million dollars or yeah
it was common folk it's the idea of it
Pat it's the idea that's what they don't
one day they can be the one day they
would also have in a state of eleven of
more than eleven millions on which they
might hypothetically have to pay tax
some day